for four months I have grown this
awkward beard and for four months I am
faced my demons every day should I shave
or should I keep it you brows have
either supported it or been against it
and today we're waiving the options
whether the beard will stay or not
let's start why I should keep the beard
Cyprien he's like well Asia ashes we a
avec une beard so you better keep it as
well he makes a fair point nice fine art
with beard or no beard you are here oh
that's sweet okay with me beard
it's me shaving wiping out the face and
I look like I'm a baby
thanks hahaha that pictures literally
from 2011 look at him walking into the
room with that beard so majestic Pierce
wit beard a [ __ ] Viking beast it's
without beard
disgusting man champ Felix and sister
found beards cool - is this what you're
gonna look like yes it is absolutely but
that is the best Photoshop I have ever
seen wow you look hot with a beard hey
damn right I do what the [ __ ] is this oh
my god this is amazing
hahaha oh that is the best fan art I've
seen in a long time dude what the Solid
Snake
what make a PewDiePie the awesome brain
of gaming nerd the beard that makes the
girls screaming man jealous roses are
red violets are blue
pewds beard look like a bush yummy hell
Craig hell yeah does my beard have a
phase in it okay now you're just getting
weird what the bruh bruh hahaha oh
that's awesome
hahahaha holy [ __ ] is that me no way
that's me my nose is not that handsome
what the [ __ ] that is beautiful alright
now let's look at you bros that wants me
to shave I want this face back goddamn
it I do look hard as [ __ ] you're right
just do it don't let the beard to be
beard you make a great point it's if you
don't shave you'll end up like this guy
I don't see a problem holy [ __ ] look at
this look at this fan tweeting so many
times oh my god oh my god dude
Ritu holy Sh it never ends it never oh
my okay oh my god it keeps going oh
there's more of them
Jesus Christ dude you know what this is
all too much I'm doing a vote and the
vote will decide once and for all this
vote is final
50/50 are you [ __ ] kidding me
oh wait it's been updated the results
are in
52% here's being 48 percent parents
Shane you know what that means
I'm keeping the beer but guess what I'm
pretty pie if I want to shame I'll shave
just watch me
what the [ __ ] I have been watching your
child for 26 long years
it is me Odin I cannot let you do this
Felix I have watched you look like a
little [ __ ] for 26 long years look at
this face
it's pathetic do not listen to your fans
PewDiePie half of them are clearly
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] pretty pie
I do what I want I got the most
subscribers I'm gonna shave mine if you
shave Oh